we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P
a few people contacted me
about the Circuit City stuff that came
up during my interview a couple weeks
ago with Patrick Bett David here's one
such voicemail
hey David I saw you on Patrick David's
podcast yes and uh I know you brought up
uh how you sold the extended service
plans at Circuit City and I just wanted
to hear the story
um it sounds like you wanted to talk
tell it and he didn't really give you a
chance so
I was curious thanks well you know it's
not really one story but it was
absolutely you know I've said before
when I worked at Circuit City when I was
in high school it really allowed me to
develop really important interpersonal
skills
for quickly building Rapport
um establishing a connection with people
getting right to the Crux of whatever it
was that brought people into the store
that day really invaluable skills that
that I'm so grateful even if Circuit
City ultimately laid me off because they
laid off everybody who was selling too
much stuff because they didn't want to
pay us when they switched from
commission to hourly but one of the most
interesting aspects of it was the
selling of extended service plans and
I've said before that at Circuit City
if you were reliably selling these
service plans you could make half to
sixty percent of your income from the
service plans rather than the products
themselves it wasn't uncommon I'm going
back a ways now but just roughly
it what and think about inflation this
was over this was 20 years ago it wasn't
uncommon that if you sold a computer you
might make 18 in commission but the
warranty associated with it would pay
you 40 bucks if the customer bought it
and we had all sorts of interesting
techniques and ideas and everybody
always tried to be creative but honest
in order to sell those service plans and
we were not incentivized to lie because
if there was a problem the people would
come back that service plan would be
refunded and you would lose the
commission so there really was not an
incentive to lie one of the things I
would often do is
I would introduce the idea of the fact
that sometimes things break and it's
better to be able to come back to the
store than they have to ship it to you
know Hewlett Packard or whatever I would
introduce it early in the process and
that made it so that it sort of sold
itself so people would come in you know
they might be looking for a laptop and
say oh well what why are you looking for
the laptop mine crapped out really how
old was it uh three years really and did
did you have an extended service plan on
it no I didn't oh you know if if you did
it might be covered you might just be
able to get it fixed that was my
Approach I wasn't coming up with any you
know confrontational techniques to start
begging people to buy warranties I would
just introduce it early and by the time
we would get to the sales point I would
say by the way
I mentioned earlier that if you had had
a service plan on your current laptop
you might not even need to get a new one
right now it's a relatively small amount
of money given how expensive computer
repairs are right now and you know at
the time it was much harder to work on
laptops than it is now so many of the
parts were self-contained and
proprietary here's what it is and it
really was was that symbol you know
there was no there was no big mystery to
it but it really was about establishing
the Rapport and building the
relationship with people anyway
it was a fascinating time and invaluable
in terms of uh the the skills that I
learned there and sadly Circuit City
decided no more commission we see Best
Buy paying people seven bucks an hour
let's switch everybody to hourly and
then within months was out I was out of
business Maybe not maybe like 18 months
or something along those lines uh so
apparently the the wrong decision so
that was the Circuit City story we have
a fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money yes everybody else would makes
money to find themselves as bad let's
make some money Alex let's do it we are
going to talk about the reports that
Nikki Haley is reportedly about to
announce she's running for president in
2024 becoming the first what we might
call major competitor Donald Trump trump
is going to lose his mind Trump and
Haley were friendly during Trump's
presidency but this is going to trigger
Trump and it's going to be very
interesting we'll discuss that secondly
Alabama Democrats want to ban employers
from being able to force workers to get
microchipped why is this even coming up
I will tell you and lastly the College
Board is slamming desantises Florida for
what it is calling slander of the
advanced placement black history course
that has been the subject of so much
controversy over the last few weeks all
of those stories and more when I am
joined by producer Pat
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss it because it
is going to be a beautiful bonus show I
will see you then